Oh exclusive live in studio was ha so
check it out Vegas you just heard that
guy say what's up say what's up again
what's going on introduce yourself man
this is Justin Bieber oh my god Justin
Bieber's in the building Las Vegas Biebs
man I gotta say you you got the city
going crazy tonight bro it's it's been
amazing man I got to go to a school and
it was was really touching you know a
lot of the kids you know don't have a
lot and me going there was was really
you know brought them out of their shell
and and got them to be happy for you
know just a moment so man it's a good
thing to do during the Christmas time
now speaking of Christmas we got you
some gifts man you know Justin Bieber
yes I got you some gifts
hey I don't know we got you here I'm
gonna let you over crack that bad boy
right here all right so we got you some
UNLV snacks you know cuz you're in Vegas
you're running rebels that now I know
your trunk we're doing the hip-hop thing
work so I got you some essential classic
hip-hop albums I feel everybody should
have I got a cracker moment I got the
first ones nas Illmatic
yep okay you don't have that already I
don't have this okay yeah you couldn't
you need that in your life being the
second one that's clips okay you don't
put your tea cuz you pick up with
kindness yes hell hath no fury yeah one
of the most underrated albums of all
time
okay you're gonna need that in your life
is don't play it around kids all right
okay and the lack Chua Lee that's afraid
he gives a mixtape which you're gonna
need that ed last out class equipment
you have that okay now you got a backup
though i do have a backup okay now you
got it back on my man so i had any ID to
bless you and i noticed that you were
doing a little cuckoo in the numerator
you're in yep I caught that oh my man I
got you an apron
thank you
it's customized it says Bieber swag on
the front yeah that's why I messed with
you man cuz you date people and you
think about Bieber swag I need to
Instagram this picture yeah I believe
that histogram well aren't you I'll hold
up so we can do it together and you
can't reply me give me a cool mm or we
could just you know a picture of me and
the apron it'd be like you
okay and look man you're in Vegas
everybody likes party in Vegas so we got
Justin on our property I see that's
wrong oh I saw a picture you as a
specific oh but that's in Mexico it's
all good over there but here you guys go
soldier hi alright so amen but for real
man has definitely been a huge two years
for you you're kind of grown up now man
like I was watching interviews of you
all night yeah doing a little research
yeah and dude it's been crazy last two
days to see a progression man how's it
feel to be like the biggest pop star on
the planet I mean I don't even really
think about it like that man I'm just
really blessed to just be where I am and
be able to travel the world and do what
I love I'm not mad at that man juicy Lou
you know you've been named Google's most
searched and most popular of 2011 man
that's crazy
that was crazy so you did the school
today when you when you perform at the
school once you let everybody kind of
know back for my wedding went perform at
that school basically I performed in the
school because on Ellen actually saw the
story thank you I saw the story
basically this woman who is - who was
taken in these children yeah and giving
them an education giving them a place to
stay giving them food and basically she
was seeing that they didn't really have
a place to go after school they were
like you know half of the kids were
homeless half the kids you know all they
had were their belongings in their bag
so she it was just heartbreaking it and
and every Friday when they when they
would leave they would be really sad
because they knew that the next time
they would get a meal was back on Monday
at school so I just wanted to be able to
help these kids out and give them you
know hope and give them inspiration let
them know that wherever you come from
this there's always a upsize you know
you you know with God anything's
possible that's what's up and you made a
donation to we saw we give them $100,000
900,000 with a toy that's a major man
shout out to Justin Bieber hey you have
the holiday album which I was checking
out I really love the song with boys
demands the following a lot of that join
us though
and then you have the record that you
wrapped along with Busta Rhymes yeah
were you intimidated to hop on a track
with one of the link you know Busta
Rhymes is one of the best ever
no sir I just I recorded my first ok I
leave Internet that's just heat I'd let
him go after me so I did it I didn't
have to be intimidated yeah you've been
dabbled in of course in the hip hop a
little bit he put off the speaking in
tongue freestyle you been rapping a lot
how far with that are you trying to go I
know your boys were ashore wrong
yes no I just having fun
you're gonna put out a rap mixtape out
like Chris Brown I'll probably not know
I might just do some fun stuff but yeah
that's what it is man hey and I also saw
online when your favorite shows it's
Dexter Dexter is awesome and you mess
with Texas that's my favorite show me
are you up on the current season what
season are you I'm on like seasons like
three okay yeah you yeah yeah okay I'm
just getting cuz I just got Fredo and
Josh got me hooked on it so those are my
homies and they like they watch a
religiously so hey so you're 17 now 18
for next 11 March months away up and
what is the first thing you're gonna do
you're gonna do anything crazy and turn
18 yeah I don't I don't plan anything
really to go go you know I don't know if
I thanks Justin are you going home for
Christmas I am going home for Christmas
and then New York City for near Z rockin
Eve yes specialist yes yes so I'm gonna
be going and see my family and getting a
rest
hey since you're like a super rich now
you know what I'm saying
I don't put your business out there but
Forbes what top 20 somebodies yeah under
30 you're in at number 2 what do you get
your folks for Christmas man cuz man if
I tell you then it's not gonna be much
of a surprise now ah what you got son
laughs what'd you get him last year last
year how about a house how about cars
all that goodness man hey so uh we were
talking to me and just you were talking
to off the air about your Christmas
album and we were somehow it was all the
proceeds for the album charity was that
your decision was at the label decision
it was both it was both of our decisions
is actually the first time that they've
ever done that gave the proceeds to
charity from the Christmas album so it's
it's really it was really special to be
able to do that yeah that's that's very
selfless man a lot of you know a lot of
artists they would I mean maybe a
percentage but all the pro see it that's
pretty major man you so you've been
vacationing a lot I see I see you on the
tabloids a lot on jet skis and stuff and
all that goodness what is like the best
part about being away from everything
because I'm sure your day-to-day life is
this look just non-stop
I mean when you get to take a break I
mean what do you like to do when
nobody's watching day-to-day life I mean
I'm just a regular 17 or I like to hang
out with friends you go to the movies
like just show play video games yeah
play video games
what's your game Todd do the NBA 2k
suitcase well yeah okay I like to K 11
better I think
Sukie 11 was better okay so I was cool
because you get to play with like more
old for players than the 12 those 11
it's a it's a it's a worst game the game
plays better yeah do you play online
though I don't okay I play online call
of duty the are you do people know it's
you though yeah like it's like J fever
night II know
no supers like slicer spice why tastic
99 is out my dad gone insane Justin why
do you keep getting pulled over and your
Batmobile I don't know let you go right
I just want to see my car they did I
think so when the cops pull you over and
they're realizing to you that when I get
I mean before the cops even checking for
humor like that like when the cop pulled
over this last time that just came out
on the news that he recognized you
yeah okay I'll let you go my man it's
Justin Bieber made you do it
yeah you want to do some donuts right
now feel a thing what some of the times
like they'll pull me over like for the
windows being too dark and then once
they see it cuz then I'm like it's
either it's either people are getting
accidents trying to look at me through
the window or I have my windows dark and
then no I definitely it's a safety issue
thank you yeah most definitely
hey so now you're getting older your new
album I heard you're working with Kanye
and Drake have you already been in the
studio with them I have been we were in
this to do what's that like man he's so
talented he's so talented I can't wait
to get back in this my main thing is
like I look like I enjoy your music with
but it's kind of you know it's kind of
like a situation like I've Justin Bieber
was back in the news it in sync he was
running it and then he kind of started
making music that you're getting older
he started making music that I could
kind of more of a late so I mean years
now that you're turning like another
Corning in life as far as your age and
stuff is your music gonna get more
friendly for I don't know an adult guy
like myself to listen to or not yeah
it's fun of yeah of course I mean that's
why I whole plan you know
when especially like a year two years
ago it was quite like it's corny for
like a 30 year olds up if I'm lying
around in my car bumping the Bieber I'm
getting I'm being looked at funny
exactly but like you know hopefully
that's our changing people but there it
is hey before you go man can we get you
to spit something for us what do you
want this
hey anything you want we got we got some
beats
Dec yeah you down come on aspire I'm
gonna do some you already spit all right
all right give him your headphones yeah
oh hey we got we got we got biggie who
shot you all right that's something
everybody grab you got a bless that
sam-i-am Justin Bieber shot nine seven
five let's go yeah yeah running
everywhere trying to find I can't hear
me I can't hear myself that happens I
know you got to turn up the beat
turn up the beat to have to be printed
offer on up yeah I go running everywhere
trying to find where I am going nowhere
so I'm trying again I am so lost like
paper no pen yes you have called so yet
Here I am
cold no sweater both no letter so much
better
my roll go get her my toll is redder and
the fire in my eyes I'm a rain know
whether the gold I must say is a whole
lot better and must when the storm from
Jehovah come I'm gonna be the best ever
love from the start
peace in my heart I'm a roll on we will
never be apart but I still wonder have I
thought the Thunder I can feel it in my
heart shooting like a hunter yeah a
straight gunner but it feels strange
another thing on my heart makes things
change how I felt before my brain
rearranged and what I knew before is
definitely not the same can I just take
a minute
yeah just wait a minute starting to hate
the minute we have to pay the minute
alright okay the minute or we go wait a
minute see how long times it just takes
to just save him and it life is so short
but we take it for granted paying up on
my life and it was a life that I was
handed trying so high and yes I just
landed I'm trying to figure out what my
plan is
his hand is on my life and my sin just
vanished my filth washes off quick like
her fake tenants I am growing up quick
like a grown man imma be set so on my
great-grandkids
it's like yo
Thanks coming through man I hope you
enjoy you know I listen to those CDs
thank you hey your boy scooter told me
you might be on the new album so I'm
looking forward to that I'm looking
forward to that anything you want to say
to the people for you out of your man
beaver swag
what's that one more time your mic is
feverish like Bieber swag there it is
nothing aside nine seven five and coming
right back don't go nowhere set out to
Justin Bieber
you